one of the beautiful things about
looting and rioting is that it just
immediately makes people's lives better
they get things that they would
otherwise have to work for weeks or
months to get they get them in an
instant the writer and activist
vicki osterweil is the latest and most
strident defender of the violence and
destruction that's accompanied more than
three months of
protests following the death of george
floyd
osterweil argues that in the last years
of martin luther king jr's life
as his focus moved beyond desegregation
and voting
rights and towards promoting socialism
he had a change of heart about looting
and destruction as a tool for social
change
though he wasn't calling for violent
revolution she writes
neither was he chastising or rejecting
rioters anymore
others have pointed to the famous king
line a riot
is the language of the unheard in
reality
king was unwavering in his commitment to
non-violence
every summer we are going to have this
kind of vigorous
protest my hope is that it will be
non-violent
i would hope that we can avoid riots
because riots are self-defeating and
socially destructive he tried to make
his position crystal clear in that same
1966
interview with 60 minutes mike wallace i
will never change
uh in my basic idea that
non-violence is the most potent weapon
available to the negro in his struggle
for freedom and justice
and less than a year before his death
king delivered a lecture addressing
skeptics of non-violence following the
1967 riots
many people feel that non-violence as
his strategy for social change
was cremated in the flames of the urban
riots of the last two years
yet king doubled down calling for
massive sustained
non-violent civil disobedience in this
world
non-violence is no longer an option for
intellectual analysis it is an
imperative for action king considered
violent protests to be self-defeating
because as he argued in 1968
every time a riot develops it makes a
right-wing takeover more likely and
helps the segregationist
george wallace vicky osterwale writes
admiringly of the nationwide riots that
followed king's
assassination as an act of pure mourning
grief and rage that perhaps felt so
natural
so immediate so appropriate even those
who would normally marvel at their scale
fell
quiet these uprisings are widely
understudied
theorized or historicized she writes
and the silence on the part of
historians scholars and activists
has been deafening but the princeton
political scientist omar wassau
has studied the 68 riots in detail
finding that they allowed
richard nixon to beat democrat hubert
humphrey in that year's presidential
race
as king understood media coverage was
why
looting and violence backfired when
protesters engaged in violence
that predicted a headline about riots
tomorrow a headline
that was much more likely to focus on
crime and disorder
and public opinion moves very closely
with that so
when the newspapers are talking about
civil rights
civil rights becomes the most important
problem in public opinion surveys
and when newspapers are heavily covering
crime and riots
crime and riots become the thing that is
the most important problem and so
the tactics that are employed by
protesters can really make a
powerful impact on how the media tell
the story
which in turn shapes public opinion some
media outlets have opted to downplay the
violence and destruction
but king's warning and wasa's research
still resonate today as polls show a
sharp downward turn in approval ratings
of the black lives matter movement in
recent weeks
especially in swing states like
wisconsin even before riots hit kenosha
democratic presidential candidate joe
biden seems to fundamentally understand
that rioting is not protesting
looting is not protesting which might
help explain how he's maintained a lead
so far
against an incumbent who's often fanned
the flames with his rhetoric
if a city or state refuses to take the
actions that are necessary to defend the
life and property
of their residents then i will deploy
the united states military
and quickly solve the problem for them
pariah
is the language of the unheard when king
said this
he wasn't excusing riots but imploring
observers
to acknowledge the unjust conditions
that contributed to their emergence
in the first place certain conditions
continue to exist in our society
which must be condemned as vigorously
as we condemn riot rioters and looters
are at the core of all of these
movements
the paths forward to social change
couldn't be more clear
persistent non-violent resistance as
practiced by martin luther king jr
who helped achieve historic civil rights
legislation or
rioting and looting promoted by
activists who believe
we need to argue and defend every tactic
that might help us
overturn this miserable world of white
supremacy
anti-blackness cis heteropatriarchy
capitalism empire and property